Look at this line.
And now, look at these
three lines. Can you tell which of them
matches that first line? And how sure are you ?
Hold that thought and listen to this story.
Because most people can get this wrong.
Once upon a time, on the eve
of a major religious holiday,
a seven year old boy was observing his
grandmother as she poured an extra glass of wine.
When the boy asked who the glass was for,
she said that it was for the prophet.
The boy didn’t believe her, so his uncle
told him to just observe the glass closely.
Full of expectation, the boy watched
the glass intently, and suddenly,
he thought he saw the level
of wine drop just a bit!
In 1951, decades after the incident, our
boy became a pioneer in social psychology,
determined to rationalize
what actually happened that
fateful night. Did some of the wine really
disappear, or was he made to believe that?
To find out the truth, he devised an experiment
to investigate whether peer pressure can be
strong enough to change our perception, and
make us believe in things that are not true.
Solomon Asch's conformity experiment was
conducted with 123 white, male college students
who were told to be part of a study in visual
judgment. Each student was introduced to a group
of 6-8 other students, who were, in fact, actors
who already knew what the experiment was about.
The group was then gathered
in a classroom and shown
two cards. The first with one line,
the second with three lines on it.
Each student was then asked to say
aloud which line in the second card
matched that first one. The group was
seated in such a way that allowed the
actors to respond first, leaving the
real participant to respond last.
For the first two rounds, the fake students,
also known as confederates, gave the correct
answer and the innocent student, known as the
subject, said whatever he thought to be true.
In the third round, the actors began
to respond with a clearly wrong answer.
For the next 12 rounds, dubbed "the
critical trials", all the confederates
would give the obviously wrong answer.
So the innocent student could either
ignore the majority or ignore the truth. So
what did the experiment tell the researchers?
Upon completing 18 rounds with all 123 subjects,
the experiment came to the following conclusion.
23% of the students always gave the right answer.
72% conformed to the majority at least once.
And 5% completely succumbed to peer pressure
and always gave the obviously wrong answer.
Asch’s work also showed that if just one
other acting student responded correctly,
the effect of peer pressure
decreased substantially.
The experiment also showed that the opinions
of three peers are enough to influence a
student to change his mind. Increasing
the number beyond three confederates,
did not increase the levels
of conformity among others.
Or put differently; if 3 people
say something obviously wrong
and there is no one to disagree with them, many
of us agree with the wrong answer and start lying,
due to our deeply human desire to fit in.
Since then, Asch’s experiment has been
successfully replicated many times and
the effect remains significant, especially
among women and homogeneous peer groups.
In 1955, Asch famously said: “The tendency
to conformity in our society is so strong
that reasonably intelligent and well-meaning young
people are willing to call white,
black. This is a matter of concern.
It raises questions about our ways of education
and about the values that guide our conduct.”
What do you think? Would you have
conformed or stuck to the truth?
Do you see the Asch’s effect in your daily
life or in social media? And what can we as
adults or educators do to give young people today
the strength to stand up and speak the truth?
Share your thoughts in the comments below!
This and all other Sprouts' videos are
licensed under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses or
to start projects - and
today, thousands already do!
To learn how it works and download this
video without Ads or background music,
checkout our website or
read the description below.
If you want to support our
mission and help change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.